- So wait, are there any
animals that you're afraid of?
- Yeah, I have actually a phobia.
- Oh, like of which
- Yeah.
- Like of which-
- I'm always called to be the collector
of the animals, like "There's a spider!
There's a tarantula!"
Okay, calm down.
I pick them up, I bring them outside.
- Yeah, me too.
- But snakes,
I don't care
- Oh.
- if it's a scorpion, I'm not afraid.
But snakes, I have a phobia.
- Yeah. So tell me.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
(Salma Hayek yells)
- Because I specifically remember
as a child going, first of all,
how many milk ads do I need to read
and drink milk to get to look like that?
(audience laughs)
You know, like those
ads when you're a kid.
And secondly, like, how
did you handle that?
That's a python, isn't it?
- I can't think because I'm still going
around the fact that you said as a kid.
- Oh. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Yeah, but that's because
we look the same age
(Salma Hayek laughs)
'cause you found the
fountain of youth. (laughs)
(Salma Hayek laughs)
Like, it's like.
- Well, you know, I had to go on trance.
Because-
- You-
- If I was not on trance,
if you look at my eyes, I look a little-
- No one was looking
- I couldn't have done it.
at your eyes. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- That's the thing.
If you really study my eyes.
- [Kelly Clarkson] If you really,
you have to focus on that.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Yeah. I mean this was,
I remember this as a kid.
I mean, even Britney Spears ended
up doing that thing,
with the Python thing.
Yeah. It was just such
a culture,
- Yeah, everybody started,
- pop culture thing.
- Yeah.
- But they didn't have
to go on trance like me.
And the thing is that you cannot-
- Did you tell them them that you like,
Quentin Tarantino, did you tell him
that you were terrified of snakes?
- Yeah.
- Oh, and you just, yeah.
- Oh yeah,
(audience laughs)
Robert Rodriguez said, well,
Madonna wants your part.
If you cannot dance with
the snake, I call Madonna.
And I'm like, Madonna
doesn't want my little part.
Okay.
(audience laughs)
So don't try to-
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- They tried to manipulate you. (laughs)
- Yes. But I did it, I was proud to,
because when you are acting,
you have to become someone else.
- Did that help? That's probably-
- Yes. Absolutely. That's
how you do everything.
But it's, I was very proud
that I was freed of my phobia.
I didn't have to
- Yeah.
- give her my phobia.
She got to be, and also you
girls are gonna like this.
I study a lot about
the meaning of a snake.
- Yeah.
- And it represents your inner power.
So my, when I was going on trance,
it was about dancing with my inner power.
Like having a dance with my inner power.
And I gotta say girls, when you are sad.
- Yeah.
- Or you feel
like you have no strength,
close the door, put some music.
- [Kelly Clarkson] This is what I do.
- And dance.
- That's what I do.
- Like nobody's watching.
(audience cheers)
Until you get chills.
(audience applauds)
- But it does, it makes
me feel so good to dance.
- Yeah.
- I love movement.
- Gives you power.
- Yeah.
And when I close my eyes,
I picture, I look like you.
(everyone laughs)